There are three kinds of inflammation in the rif. They are all 36 minutes. How can
we know what is each frequency for and for what work? Not exactly sure what
you're asking are three programs for inflammation of the rif. I've got positive
what you're asking there. Let's talk about rif programs running other programs for a
second. So let's say I have a sinus infection or you have inflammation. Well,
what program should I run? Well, if there's an inflammation program you can try
that. If there's a swelling program, you can try that. I have sinus infections.
Well, goodness, there's four or five sinus infection programs. So which one should
I use? The answer is these are frequencies. They're different frequency sets that
practitioners like me have created that have worked for some people. So try them.
You just have to try all of them. Try them at different times. And you have to try them
more than once. I ran the stubborn sinus program and it didn't help at all. Run it
again. Run it three or four times. It's still not helping. Well, maybe run the
different sinus program. It's still not helping. Well, maybe run a bacterial
program. Maybe run a virus program. So you kind of have to think through this
a little bit. Don't feel bad about trying different things. So these are
frequencies. So you have a frequency may really help you. It made for one
day and it might not help you for something else that's similar to that. That's why
there's multiple programs for strap infection. Why are there multiple programs?
Because there's not just one frequency for strap. So you want to run these different
programs. And experiment with them and try them. That's why I think these should
be your first go to. So it's not a cure all. It should be your first go to with
any symptom that you have.
Long time ago, I shared, I probably haven't shared it for a while. That this is
Oh gosh, it was like eight, nine years ago. I had a frozen shoulder. I hurt my
left shoulder. Really bad lifting weights. And I couldn't move my arm. I couldn't
move my shoulder. I had my arm in a sling for two weeks. I didn't even think to
use the right machine. Why? Because it's my shoulder. I damaged my rotator cuff
or whatever I damaged in there. I thought I was going to have to do a new surgery.
Finally, my wife said, you just need to call the orthopedic surgeon and go in. You're
being so stupid here in your stubbornness. Okay. I could be an extremely stubborn
person. So and then my colleague at the time, this doctor that I had worked for me said,
why don't you run the right and try the accelerated healing program. I did that first
one thing that I had and it worked. It could be honest with you. I never thought of it.
Every across my mind to run the right for my damaged shoulder because I thought I tore
my rotator cuff. I was pretty sure I had torn it.
My arm was in a sling. I was taking Tylenol every three hours during the day.
And I never take Tylenol. So that's how painful it was. I ran the accelerated healing
program, which is in the normalizing frequency folder of your wife. It took my pain away
completely. And how I do it is that first of all, I didn't have pigs. I was taking Tylenol
every three hours and I had to take it. I had to take it when I paid ramped up.
I forgot to take Tylenol because I didn't have the pain because it, you know, the program fixed it.
I still don't know physiologically how that worked.
But I ran it one time. This is before I had a knife at home. I didn't have a knife at home at that time.
So it had about nine years ago. And I ran it at the office. I ran the accelerated healing program
which is about an hour to half.
I still kept my arm in a sling because I was convinced if I take this out of my sling,
it's just going to go me and just give me a zegger. And I thought I'm just going to keep it in the sling.
Friday, I was at home. I still kept it in the sling. I thought this is really stupid.
But my pain has gone. I got to take the sling off.
So I took the sling off right after noon. And my arm was still stuck in that sling position
because it bent like that for two weeks.
And I slowly by Saturday, I was kind of putting my arm down by my side and slowly moving it
because I was convinced it was just going to flare up again and be back to the way it was.
And I was convincing my brain and I'll guess I'll just hold my arm in a sling position the rest of my life to be out of pain.
But slowly moved it around. The pain never came back. I did the program again Monday when I came in the office.
And I think I did it one more time. The pains never returned. I can lift weights. I don't have any problems with my left shoulder.
I don't know how it fixed it. Maybe it just blocked the pain cycle enough that it healed. But I can't believe that's the truth because
it's a tile block the pain cycle and it wasn't healing. So whatever it worked. It's frequencies.
So when people go, why don't believe in frequencies? Okay, well, then stop using your cell phone. Stop, stop living because everything is frequencies.
So if you hit the right frequencies, good things can happen. So don't, don't feel bad about experimenting with that tool that you have in your house.
One of the saddest thing that we see is we have patients that will pass away and we'll get the right back from them.
And we have a way to look on the right and see the last time you used it. I shouldn't be telling you this.
But we have a way to look and you see this person passed away in March and they stopped using the right. They haven't used it for seven months. It's like what the means.
You have this great tool. Though it's not a magic wand. It is amazing. So use it. Use it for whatever you want to use it for. You're not going to burn the thing out. You're not going to hurt yourself with it.
Use this thing and experiment with different frequencies and different programs.
And tell you find and hit on what's going to be best for you.
Currently on our house, we have two rifes in our house. My grown kids have a rife machine in their house.
Use it for my grandkids or whatever they have going on. You should use this tool to the best of your ability.